stay true to myself stay pretty true to
whatever my instincts are you've got to
stay true to who you are yourself stay
true to who I am to myself I had to be
true hello believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can stay
true to yourself and as always as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it in the comments below and put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired as well enjoy I haven't had any
regrets you know it there and it's
sometimes really hard I'll tell you a
funny story I remember right before I
got a different world I auditioned for
blossom remember the TV show absolutely
yes you remember her friend the young
girl her six I auditioned for six okay
and I had my hair up in a little
ponytail with this little jumpsuit I
looked like I was about 12 but got the
role okay got the role to play six and I
was like I was 18 19 years old then I
said I looked at my agent Nancy ran for
it
I said Nancy I can't do this I just
can't do it this is I'm gonna be
miserable playing a twelve-year-old on
this show I can't do this and we had to
turn it down and I and let me tell you
then folks were not happy it's like this
girl this she is you know that whole
thing but within two weeks I got a
different world and that really taught
me a lesson which was you know to really
listen to and and follow my gut because
everything that that shines isn't gold
you know what I mean and so it really
taught me a very valuable lesson to just
stay true to myself if there's nothing
that I haven't
about this business it's really about
staying true to why I'm here
why you know I started acting in the
first place and and what's important to
me and keeping my artistic integrity as
well as my creative like my personal
integrity and that was a big lesson for
me and let me tell you that was not an
easy thing to turn down you know being a
young actress you got this opportunity
for you know this this series regular is
money you know but I just felt deeper
down inside I was like something's
coming your way just fall back and then
I got to meet you know Debbie Allen and
it's kind of like I'm always been an
outcast because they never see me I know
without having if you went into the
music or just us in general like you
made me a person I'm just serious now
but I'm always I'm surprised I've said
this it's kind of cool this is what's
gonna make us great in the future that
they here today do a lot of jokes and
there's always be yourself that's when
one thing I might just do with the life
that's what I try to tell people just to
do with the person others and that's why
at the end of the day I'm always gonna
make the music I want to make
you get so caught up ye canna first out
one battery light was pretty successful
the teeth are like something like that I
can't its progression I'm gonna hold if
[Music]
I'm gonna make the music that I want to
make now that sounds good to me
you know I might even do your organic
two years from now making some
off-the-wall music today I stayed pretty
true to whatever my instincts are as an
artist sometimes for worse at first
because I think when you do something
that's out of the norm you have to keep
doing it for a little while to make it
your own norm so it's an exciting idea
to me that I could be putting a record
out and being able to be my own person
to not have to think about what I can't
say or can't do because I don't want to
lose people's understanding of what I do
as a convention you know so I'm really
excited about the idea of people going
oh no that's him that's him
you know you get new video all the time
all the time
so this is actually a video of a
firefighter rescuing and resuscitating
Canton yeah and a video like that would
very easily go viral around the world oh
my god
yeah and that's essentially a commercial
for GoPro essentially a commercial for
GoPro it's a marketers dream and it's
all based off of authenticity right it's
it's our customers doing interesting
things around the world and they're so
stoked that they're able to finally self
document these things that they like to
do and share with people they're so
stoked at how good they look in the
video that when they share the video
they often give us credit my GoPro ski
trip my GoPro day at the park with my
kids you're the only CEO or interviewed
who's used the word stoked like five
million times yes well you know it's
it's you you you've got to stay true to
who you are and and I recognize that my
approach to life and are now our
company's approach to life is what has
made GoPro what it is and so there's no
reason to change that you have to be
authentic I mean you've got no hope if
you try to pretend to be Reed Hastings
or Mark Zuckerberg or Bill Gates or
whoever you want to think your CEOs are
that you've met you know that is crazy
and you got to really get comfortable
with yourself your strengths and
weaknesses people are inspired by
authenticity and I'm just surprised how
many people feel like they're acting and
or try to act and you may be a really
quiet person and that's fine
but if you have that fierce will that
desire for the institution the company
to be great and your own role and that
is secondary and you authentically
Express that whatever ways you do then
you'll be greatly accepted okay and so
that's all it takes is to be authentic
and not try to be something else and to
fundamentally care at your core about
what's good for the company and if
everybody knows and you act in the
notion of what's good as best as your
judgement can tell what's good for the
cup
they will see that and people will
follow you and they won't be cynical
it's when you hide things it's when you
pretend that you lose trust very quickly
man you just got to stay true to
yourself you know never try to follow
the trends that's when you get lost in
the sauce man you gotta do what you feel
man and be creative and don't be scared
to be yourself and I always keep that
faith you know I've been in the darkest
times of my life man where I didn't know
what was gonna happen I was flat broke
anything you could think of man I hadn't
been through it and like you know you
got to be strong enough to make it
through and it just makes it that much
sweeter when everything starts going
right when she was 17 years old
Stephanie got her high school diploma
and left the nuns to join the
prestigious Tisch School of Arts a
school entirely dedicated to artistic
disciplines
she took numerous classes such as arts
story music theater and dancing I was
really blessed and lucky to get in I got
in very early I was 17 and I was one of
20 people in in America that got into
the school early and I was really happy
and excited and I just felt like all my
dreams were coming true and it was a
wonderful school but it was very factory
like not in the Warhol factory like way
more like a sausage link factory where
everyone was taught the same sorts of
things and and I think what I didn't
like about this school was I felt that
they wanted us all to be the same and
possess the same skills and I had
something very different inside of me
you think the secret to your success is
actually that you are in many ways in
the way you lead your life your tastes
are quite average middle-of-the-road the
kind of stuff that the mass market would
like for sure absolutely right
and I don't think you can make records
other that you can make TV shows
properly unless you can sit there as a
listener or a viewer you can't guess
what people like it would be like me
guessing what you want for dinner it's
impossible I can tell you what I want
so I base everything on my own tastes
and I have you know fairly broad you
know I would say quite simple tastes
I mean
terrible as it is the kid who had the
girls in the neighborhood who had the
nicest car and sold the most drugs you
know there wasn't really anybody that I
could look up to that was from my
situation I really made something of
himself that's why I feel is so
important to stay true to who I am and
where I'm from you know because kids
like myself do look up to me you know
and I came through it the right way you
know so it really you know makes them it
gives them something to look at you know
and something to work for you know and
that's why I've accomplished really
everything that I've set out to do but
to to just stop and not stay on that
mission I think would be wrong too
because things are still getting worse
you know what I'm saying
which one mother is this coming master
you didn't think I was gonna do it did
you thought oh he's on staying in I know
he's gonna say mother I fooled you
fooled you too my too bad own self be
true
so to myself I had to be true
I'm not gonna litter it because we're
about conversation with mother as I
usually do if you know anything about me
I'm gonna live in him I'm gonna limit
maybe twelve thirteen mother through the
whole thing because I would like
possibly to get a few seconds on see any
but if I don't make it thank you guys so
much for watching I'd love to know what
did you think what was your favorite
clip what was a single biggest message
that you learned from this that you are
going to immediately apply to your life
or your business leave in the comments
below I'm gonna join in the discussion
also I'm curious how are you staying
true to yourself what are the some of
the things that you're doing in your
life consistently to stay true to stay
authentic leave it in the comments I'm
gonna join in the discussion finally I
want to give a quick shout to obtain
eudaimonia it's a YouTube channel run by
an awesome guy named Adam who recently
made an animated book summary of my book
your one word that I really really
appreciate it so go check out his
channel as well his book explains the
secrets of how one word can transform
you and your business thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon